eike é uma satisfação enorme
obrigado e me proporcionar esse momento
opções que estamos sentindo agora mas eu
vim falar que agora do trabalho que eu
faço para realizar um sonho o sonho de
poder contribuir de alguma forma como
vocês todos estão fazendo aqui e como
vários líderes já apareceram aqui e eu
também quero seguir esses líderes e
seguindo esses dias com o meu sonho que
é contribuir de alguma forma para o
desenvolvimento da robótica no país no
brasil pra fazer isso a gente tem
trabalhado numa plataforma robótica
livre
isso é um movimento que acontece nas
universidades e nas escolas técnicas a
gente trabalha é fomentando para que
haja pesquisas avançadas na área de
robótica pesquisas aplicadas
é a gente consegue construir novos
produtos produtos inovadores formando
empreendedores mas sobretudo o que a
gente faz mesmo é a transformação com a
robótica em escolas de ensino
fundamental e médio com programas de
experimentação da robótica que são
acessíveis para todos e não com os quais
nós conseguimos às vezes se transformar
a vida das pessoas que participam deles
é pra gente fazer isso né pra gente é
construir se esse sistema essa
comunidade nessa plataforma são várias
pessoas idéias tecnologias e conteúdos
disponibilizados num lugar
disponibilizado para todos com software
livre com o desenvolvimento colaborativo
e pra gente construir isso deve
disponibilizar essas ferramentas é foi
preciso construir e desconstruir muita
coisa e é sobre isso que eu vou falar
agora sobre a desconstrução sobre como
nós trabalhamos essa discussão é como se
fosse um a torre de katas 11 uma fila de
dominós é quem nunca brincou que esse
passatempo
nós ficamos às vezes muito tempo
montando construindo horas e horas para
montar uma fila enorme
a gente dá um toque um pouco segundos
a discussão acontece e aí a gente vai
ter
é muito tempo para construir aquilo mas
se a gente conseguir tirar essa parte da
construção
imagina se a gente conseguir trabalhar
com aquelas pilhas aquelas pessoas já
estão prontas as pessoas simplesmente
trabalhando a desconstrução
é isso que a gente tem feito com a
robótica a gente a gente consegue trazer
o conhecimento que as pessoas já têm
começamos com robôs prontos de fácil
interação jogamos em qualquer criança
hoje consegue interagir com esses
brinquedos
qualquer criança consegue fazer essas
coisas funcionarem
eles primeiro interagem sem saber muito
bem o que está acontecendo ali mas com o
tempo a curiosidade faz com que eles
entendam o que tem ali dentro e é isso
que eu vou tentar mostrar aqui um
pouquinho e pouco tempo como funciona
pra gente começar a falar disso eu vou
começar desconstruindo alguns
preconceitos
o primeiro é que a robótica tecnologia é
algo complicado é algo pra cientistas
malucos superdotados nerds
eu acho que a gente tem esse estigma é
que foi criado pelos é escritor de
ficção científica que foram eles os
culpados nem escrever 10 desenhos
frankstein né
somente um super cientista é capaz de
dar vida a um ser artificial é essa
imagem eu acho que ela fica complicada
mas esses mesmos escritores eles também
são legais
eles também criam tecnologia neowin o
batman em 1.400 em 1940 mais ou menos
aqueles 40
falando no telefone celular no carro se
ele tivesse falado você acha que a gente
teria inventado telefone celular
queríamos colocar o skype
videoconferência sem ter visto jackson
um desenho animado
são eles eles são os culpados os
escritores de ficção científica a
palavra roubo foi utilizado pela
primeira vez uma peça de teatro em 1920
e esse cara aqui que escrevia obras de
ficção no século 19 nem 1950 os
conceitos do cérebro eletrônico das leis
da robótica foram impostas por ele e
hoje nas pesquisas que fizemos à
robótica nos ainda levamos em
consideração aquilo que ele escreveu
não como técnico o engenheiro mesmo
escritor
bom eu acho que é fato que a tecnologia
está presente né
todo mundo ainda seus tablets celulares
é o tempo todo aí postando no twitter
que eu tô falando já vi um monte de the
post no twitter e há pouco tempo atrás a
intenção de contratar técnico
especializado eu trabalhei com isso pra
gente está um software no computador é
não ligar para o técnico que prestava um
editor de texto aqui pra mim
hoje em dia as pessoas já estavam seus
próprios aplicativos até sistemas
operacionais as pessoas
acho que tem um monte de gente brincando
vamos instalar um sistema pensou se um
outro mas um dom buti na minha máquina
todo mundo já tá brincando disso até a
programação não é quem é e nunca
programou um gerenciador de e mails por
exemplo mandar uma mensagem automática
quando se pede férias é realmente um ano
e meio
é um programa que você faz quando uma
lista de músicas que fica tocando media
player você vai lá e programa sua
seqüência deles na galera todo mundo
lidando com a programação sem saber que
está fazendo programação né
as coisas complicadas é a computação a a
tecnologia também com ela permite ouvir
coisas mais complexas um pouquinho do
que sua programação é a computação
física atua programa a computação física
é o que está muito na moda e algumas
tecnologias em facilitando é alguém já
ouviu falar do im é uma plataforma que
permite com que pessoas sem muito
conhecimento sem muito esforço consigam
programar um microcontrolador um
microcontrolador até pouco tempo atrás
eu trabalhava com um sistema embarcado
era coisa de gente precisava de fazer
uma sede que precisava de ter uma
especialidade muito grande para a gente
conseguir programar um microcontrolador
hoje em dia qualquer pessoa consegue
pegar um microcontrolador e fazer seus
programas têm uma plataforma chamada
tamarino que está sendo desenvolvido em
recife por ricardo brazileiro do grupo
chic um coletivo e desenvolvimento de
tecnologia
essa ferramenta permite que qualquer
pessoa sem nunca ter visto eletrônica
consiga criar um circuito eletrônico e
conseguia ligar
o circuito não é doença e fazer seus
experimentos que interagem com um meio
ambiente bom
o segundo conceito que eu queria
desconstruir agora é sobre a forma de
ensinar
eu acho que a gente é eu querer
desconstruir essa questão de ter que
construir muita coisa tem que falar tem
que ter uma base de conhecimento para
poder ensinar algo em 2010 eu comecei a
o nosso primeiro programa e de
voluntário de desenvolvimento da
robótica permanece na robótica para as
meninas as escolas públicas
imagina como eu ia ser um desafio eu
ensinar robótica para pessoas que não
tinham nenhuma sequer uma base do ensino
fundamental muito sólida
mas aí eu lembrei do meu os primeiros
empregos os primeiros trabalhos que eu
tive na década de 90 era professor de
linguagens de programação
essas escolinhas cursinhos de
informática e lança nessa escola a gente
trabalhava a mesma metodologia que era
muito utilizado até hoje muita gente
utiliza isso que foi utilizado quando
aprendi na qual a gente antes de ensinar
programar a gente vai ensinar a lógica
são dois meses e meio de curso só
falamos de sócrates aristóteles
proposições premissas
quando a gente vai chegar no ponto de
falar sobre algoritmos fluxogramas
metade da turma e desistiu eu quero que
dependendo queria filosofa ali e os
resistentes que segura e naquela época
os caras que conseguimos a luz que
conseguiam passar essa parte tortuosa da
lógica e conseguir pela primeira vez
colocar a mão numa ferramenta
desenvolver programas e consegui ir lá
fazer seus programas
ele não sabia de longe porque ele tinha
estudado alguma porque não sabia como
que aplicar
então aquilo ali foi me perturbando mas
aconteceu uma coisa interessante chegou
uma empresa pra encontrar fazer um
contrato lá com essa escolinha que eu
dava aula e é essa empresa com um até
nem generosa com o pagamento sabe mas
ele exigiu o curso não pode demorar mais
que dois meses você tem dois meses para
ensinar
mudei toda a minha abordagem ensino já
foi direto o primeiro dia de aula eu vou
te ferrar
de programação vamos fazer os programas
aqui nem nada de lógica no pessoal
começou a programar desenvolver seus
programas um negócio foi acontecendo e
eu vim aqui com o tempo as próprias
pessoas conseguiam criar seus próprios
da própria lógica cada um criar a sua
lógica de acordo com a necessidade que
ele encontrando e um pouco tempo a gente
conseguiu ensinar às pessoas e viu que é
a gente poderia trabalhar uma a de uma
forma diferente no final a gente gastava
meia hora para falar de lógica e o
aprendizado daquela turma e lógica era
muito maior do que de todas as turmas
que já tinham passado ante bom voltando
aqui por nossa desconstrução eu peguei
essa ideia que já tinha vivido nada de
certa forma e trouxe para a sala de aula
então a gente começou trabalhando com os
menos assim no pronto para o detalhe
pegavam um programa pronto que é legal
também que tem que rodar em computadores
que estão presentes no dia a dia das
meninas tudo é com os robozinhos prontos
entregava aquele prédio para despertar o
interesse e eles começam a mexer abolir
as crianças de hoje em dia elas estão
num contexto de tecnologia é que é muito
interessante é como usuários eles já
estão lidando com tecnologias que há
pouco tempo atrás era impossível de se
conceber como curiosos eles conseguem
entender eles tentam eles querem saber
como que aquilo foi montado e como
hackers
eles querem mudar eles querem mudar a
forma de interação e que é da nova
funcionalidade para aquilo que aquela
tecnologia
nós temos que abrir disponibilizar fazer
com que eles possam realmente fazer isso
e é dessa forma que a gente foi
conseguindo toda essa construção hoje em
dia temos um monte de estudantes aí
programando desenvolvendo seus softwares
sistemas eletrônicos conseguem sou
darfur a apresenta um projeto aprender a
falar inglês só para poder ler os
manuais técnicos e tem uma galerinha lá
os lotes que estão conversando com os
fornecedores no exterior pelo skype
comprará a alunos que não falavam não
tinha outra língua pouco tempo
bom gente um exemplo de fazer isso nem a
gente pega um código bem complicado de
sair
e um código gerado isso aqui tá a gente
eu peço aqui ensino pra ele que se
apertar o botãozinho esse código vai
para dentro da placa ele vai lá e
apertar o botãozinho começa a ver o
levezinho com escala na placa ou um
motorzinho mexi né
é interessante que ele faz sem entender
o que está no código mas ele entende
como é desintoxicante e sem falar nada
os meios vão lá e começam a mudar esses
números que estão aí não ia mudar que ia
mudar e como ele vê lá o led já tá
piscando diferente
ainda é pouco ele é engenheiro mineiro
como é que eu faço pra poder liga então
ele vem com a dúvida então eu vou
explicar aquela dúvida que ele está
tendo num tô tendo que se num monte de
longe não ele quer resolver um problema
e ele consegue resolver
dessa forma tenho a gente tem um
estudante que é uma ferramenta funcional
ele não consegue fazer uma frase correta
enquanto na língua portuguesa mas ele
consegue programar um é do ine fazer o
robozinho deles houve qualquer trabalho
que a gente queira bom terceiro e último
é ponto que eu queria é o preconceito
que eu queria
desconstruir aqui é com relação à
entrada na universidade em relação à
inclusão né não às vezes a gente está
muito preocupado aí com o sistema de
entrada no vestibular enem é agora
sistema de cota
mas será que aí o problema na
experiência que eu tô tendo eu acho que
o problema não é a forma da prova não
seria um é é um ponto importante sim é
um perdão a um primeiro mostra né
mas ele não é tudo quantas crianças
sequer pensam ou sonham em ir para a
universidade que acham que ele é
impossível
na família ninguém foi o pai o tio
estudar ou quando muito segundo grau
foram próximo emprego então vivendo
aquela forma todo mundo vive assim vive
bem porque você é diferente porque é uma
coisa universidade eu não posso
com esses programas de experimentação da
robótica com outros eventos que a gente
tem visto aqui a gente consegue mudar
esse patamar fazer com que essas pessoas
acreditem que eles possam ir para a
faculdade
eles vêm fazendo um experimento da
robótica que eles podem desenvolver
pesquisa e pesquisa aplicada que se eles
estudar eles vão ter condições
no final das contas
os coleguinhas dele vendo eles ali
participando de eventos apresentando
trabalho eles passam a ser líder e
referência daqueles meninos que deixem
de ver que ele é amiguinho que comprar
um tênis novo e começa a ver que aquele
cara que está apresentando o trabalho
que está jogando tênis sendo campeão de
tênis
aquele sim é o líder é aquele cara que
ele tem que seguir o que ele consegue
bom
construí muita coisa só para a gente
terminar um pouquinho aqui eu vou falar
um pouco do que a gente construiu também
né a gente tem hoje é já passamos
público mais ou menos sete escolas lá no
recife mais ou menos 300 estudantes
foram participaram desses programas a
maioria deles seguem continua nesses
programas como multiplicadores
como é trabalhando em algumas empresas
parceiras como hino para a universidade
com bolsas de pesquisa
esses programas de experimentação da
robótica eles não visam o ensino da
robótica não há intenção ali é construir
centros de pesquisa em cada escola em
cada instituição que a gente passa a
gente tenta deixar um ambiente propício
para que haja pesquisa e desenvolvimento
a gente incentiva que eles publicam em
papers que eles participem de eventos de
tecnologia de eventos culturais de arte
e tecnologia
eles aprendem a furar soldar fazer busca
a programar
eles aprendem design eles aprendem que a
robótica não é só engenharia
eles vêem que a robótica veio das artes
eles participam de eventos de computação
em arte
eles aprendem a que podem ir para a
universidade que podem se incluir que
podem trabalhar e que podem transformar
na mesma forma que a gente tem feito só
os robozinhos que vão aparecendo por aí
é e mais um bocado de coisa
num segundo patamar a gente trabalha com
a outra coisa que a gente chama de
centro de desenvolvimento colaborativo
essas é esses centros a gente estava
anormalmente universidades escolas
técnicas
nós estamos hoje em cerca de 30
instituições espalhadas por todo o
brasil e uma no uruguai
essas é esse centro de desenvolvimento
colaborativo eles visam à pesquisa
aplicada na área da robótica então a
gente fomenta o material é elevando se
valeu esses estudantes para participarem
de eventos para fazer a oficina fazendo
um intercâmbio é a gente contribui para
que haja a pesquisa aplicada então eles
participam de robocop é robô campinense
principais eventos de robótica do mundo
estão indo disputar a gente consegue é
de certa forma criar produtos porque a
gente também tem um contato muito legal
nem sempre aparece uma empresa aparece
alguém que olha queria um desenvolver
uma tecnologia para resolver algum
problema
então a gente leva esse problema esse
centro de desenvolvimento colaborativo e
eles desenvolvem esse produto e essa
empresa investe neles
muitas vezes em forma empreendedores
também com esses produtos que são
criados por fim a gente trabalha também
com 11 palestras com oficinas de
desmistificação da tecnologia
são oficinas de duas horas a oito horas
independente da duração a gente sempre
faz roubos nessas oficinas pessoas que
nunca interagiram nunca tiveram um
contato com a tecnologia consegue fazer
é hoje em dia a gente faz cerca de 30
eventos anuais mais ou menos
bom gente isso é uma plataforma robótica
é nós somos hoje 1.200 e 184 pessoas
fazendo essa discussão
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]